GRAB YOUR POPCORN BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE FIGHTING AGAIN.
JOE MANSION IS FURIOUS WITH JOE
BIDEN AFTER THE PRESIDENT
PROMISED TO SHUT DOWN ALL COAL
PLANTS ACROSS AMERICA.
>> WE ARE NOW CHANGING THE
NATURE.
FOLKS, IT IS ALSO NOT CHEAPER TO
GENERATE HISTORY.
WE WILL BE SHUTTING THESE PLANTS
DOWN ALL ACROSS AMERICA AND
HAVING WIND AND SOLAR.
ALL THEY ARE DOING IS SAVING A
HELL OF A LOT OF MONEY.
>> JOE MANSION DEMANDING BIDEN
APOLOGIZE IN A STATEMENT THAT
SAYS "PRESIDENT GUIDANCE
COMMENTS ARE NOT ONLY OUTRAGEOUS
AND DIVORCED FROM REALITY THEY
IGNORE THE SEVERE ECONOMIC PAIN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE FEELING
BECAUSE OF RISING ENERGY COSTS.
COMMENTS LIKE THESE ARE THE
REASONS AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
LOSING TRUST IN PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND HE DOES NOT UNDERSTAND THE
NEED TO HAVE AN ALL IN ENERGY
POLICY THAT WOULD KEEP OUR
NATION TOTALLY ENERGY
INDEPENDENT AND OUR NATION
SECURE.
FORCED TO ONE AGAIN CLEANUP
BIDEN'S REMARKS BY SAYING HIS
WORDS HAD BEEN "TWISTED".
THE FIRST QUESTION THAT I HAVE,
JESSE, WHEN BIDEN GOES IN AFTER
MAKING A TONE DEAF STATEMENT
LIKE AT THE DETRIMENT OF
DEMOCRATS RUNNING ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY, WHO COMES OUT AND
DECIDES THAT THEY NEED TO CLEAN
IT UP?
WHO WILL BEHIND THE CURTAINS IS
CALLING THE SHOTS AND SAYING
THIS HAS TO BE REDONE.
THIS HAS TO BE RE- EXPLAINED.
>> TREASURY, ENERGY, EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT HE PUT HIS FOOT IN
HIS MOUTH.
THEY ALL KNOW THAT JOE SCREWED
UP.
I DON'T KNOW WHO TO ROOT FOR IN
THIS FIGHT.
CONVINCING ME NOT TO HIT MANSION
THAT HARD.
I MAY HIT HIM LESS HARD.
THIS GUY GAVE JOE BIDEN A
TRILLION IN A GREEN SLUSH FUND.
HE BROKE MY HEART.
LET'S PUT IT THAT WAY.
JOE BIDEN SAYS WE WILL GET RID
OF : DO WIND AND SOLAR.
THAT IS NOT WHAT DELAWARE DID.
DELAWARE GOT RID OF COAL AND
THEN JUST USES NATURAL GAS.
92% NATURAL GAS.
THEY DON'T HAVE A SINGLE
OFFSHORE WIND TURBINE.
WHY DOESN'T SOMEBODY ASK JOE
BIDEN WHY?
ALSO, WHERE ARE THESE WORKERS
GOING TO GO WORK WHEN THEY GET
FIRED FROM THESE OLD JOBS?
WILL THEY JOIN FORCES WITH THE
LAID-OFF KEYSTONE PIPELINE GUYS?
WILL THEY GO MAKE ELECTRIC
BATTERIES SOMEWHERE?
IT IS KIND OF A LONG COMMUTE.
>> ALSO, DANA, DEAR MEMBER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHEN WE
LOST HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
ARE WE BACK TO SOLAR PANELS
AGAIN?
>> SOLYNDRA WAS OUR FAVORITE
STORY ON THE FIVE.
THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD HAVE
WATCHED US THEN AS WELL.
>> REMEMBER WHEN WE THOUGHT THAT
THAT WAS SOMETHING.
JOE BIDEN JUST SAID WHAT HE
TRULY BELIEVES.
HILLARY CLINTON SAID THE SAME
THING.
ALL THE DEMOCRATS, YOU CAN'T SAY
THAT.
IT IS, THEY NEED THAT LEFT WING
SIDE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO
BE ENERGIZED IN THE ELECTION.
THAT IS WHY THEY SAY.
THE WHITE HOUSE CAME OUT AND
SAID WE APOLOGIZE BUT JOE
BIDEN'S WORDS WERE TWISTED.
NOBODY TWISTED IT.
HE ACTUALLY SAID THAT.
YOU SAY WHAT YOU MEAN YOU MEAN
WHAT YOU SAY.
THE POLITICAL REALIGNMENT THAT
IS HAPPENING IS PRETTY
INTERESTING WITH WORKING-CLASS
VOTERS.
JOE MANSION IS UP FOR REELECTION
IN 2024 AND I THINK THAT HE WILL
HAVE A VERY TELFER RACE ON HIS
HANDS.
>> THAT IS INTERESTING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, HAROLD.
>> WHEN A PARTY CAN HAVE AN OPEN
FEUD TWO DAYS BEFORE AN
ELECTION.
YOU DO NOT SEE THIS ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
I HOPE IF REPUBLICANS TAKE THE
SENATE, I HOPE THEIR VOICES
STAND UP TO REPUBLICANS WHEN
THEY THINK THEY ARE SPENDING
MUCH, GOING OVERBOARD, BEING
EXCESSIVE.
THERE IS NO QUESTION WE NEED
MORE DOMESTIC ENERGY PRODUCTION
IN THE COUNTRY.
ANY FOSSIL FUEL THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO PRODUCE HERE WHEN WE ARE THE
BIGGEST PRODUCER FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME.
IT HAPPENED UNDER HIM.
NOT ONLY SHOULD WE HAVE AN ALL
ABOUT STRATEGY, ANY REPUBLICAN,
PLEASE DON'T SUPPORT PUTIN.
IF WE EXPAND THE HORIZON AND
STRENGTH OF AN AUTOCRAT AND WE
EXPAND HIS ABILITY TO PRODUCE
NATURAL GAS AND FOR THAT MATTER
PRODUCE ENERGY PRODUCTS.
THE GREATEST IS GAS PRICES AND
ENERGY PRICES.
WE SHOULD PRODUCE MORE CARE AND
SUPPORT ZELINSKI.
IF THIS THING IS ENRICHED, IT
WILL ONLY MAKE ENERGY MORE
EXPENSIVE WHICH MAKES FOOD MORE
EXPENSIVE.
THINGS MAKING YOUR SUITS DARKER.
THE REALITY IS WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE PRODUCE MORE HERE AND WE
DO NOT EMPOWER PUTIN IN THE
PROCESS.
>> AMEN.
>> WITH RESPECT, HE SHOULD NOT
EVEN BE IN THE PICTURE.
WE SHOULD BE ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
WHOSE FAULT IS THAT?
>> A DEMOCRAT.
>> EXACTLY.
I BLAME HAROLD FORD.
FOR EVERYTHING.
EVERYTHING THAT HAS GONE WRONG
IN MY LIFE.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT THINK THAT GETS ME MAD, IT
WAS NOT GETTING RID OF COAL
PLANTS, IT IS WHEN HE SAID WIND
AND SOLAR.
IF THAT IS HOW YOU FEEL, YOU
FIRST.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOT RELYING
ON WHEN SPIRIT WHITE HOUSE IS
NOT RELYING ON SOLAR.
HE IS LYING.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IT GOT STARTED,
BUT WE POLITICIZED EVEN ENERGY.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS
BASICALLY OBJECTIVE VIEW THAT,
YEAH, LET'S USE THIS STUFF,
MAYBE IT'S NOT THAT GREAT, BUT
IN THE MEANTIME, LET'S DO THIS.
HOW DID IT BECOME LEFT AND
RIGHT?
WHEN DID THIS HAPPEN?
I GUESS YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW THE
MONEY AND FIND OUT WHO MAKES
MONEY BY PITTING US AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
WHEN GRETA -- WHAT IS HER NAME
-- DON'T GET RID OF THE NUCLEAR
POWER PLANTS BECAUSE WE NEED
THEM, THAT TELLS YOU THAT MAY BE
STUFF IS STARTING TO CRACK.
THE LAST THING IS, WHEN I LISTEN
TO BIDEN, HE REMINDS ME OF A
BINGO SPINNER.
USE BENNETT, PAUL POPS OUT, THAT
IS HIS BRAIN.
AND THEN HE READS WHAT IS ON THE
BALL.
GOT TO GET RID OF COAL PLANTS.
AND THEN HE THROWS THE BALL AWAY
AND HE DOES IT AGAIN.
HE IS BASICALLY A BINGO BA